hisoka vs kite who would win in a fight
battle it's actually quite a close match
but I think we have the answer to be
clear our contenders in this match are
pre-death kite and also pre-death hisoka
because post-death kite and post death
hisoka are out of this world powerful
and currently impossible to quantify now
statistically speak English just put
this out there hisoka starts this
discussion with a clear advantage and
the stats I'm referring to are the ones
detailed in the data book which assign
characters a score out of five in the
areas of Mind skill body Nan Ingenuity
and intelligence so what you do is you
add those six fives together and you get
a total score out of 30. with hisoka's
most recent stats from Greed Island
giving him a stat score of 25 out of 30
whereas kite lands at 23 out of 30. and
that Gap pretty much comes down to a
single area the difference between
hisoka and kite is the Ingenuity
category kite's most recent score is a
kind of mid three out of five whilst
hisokas is a perfect five and in fact
it's hisoka's only perfect score which
is what gives hisokus such an edge in
high level nen combat he's dangerously
creative and never runs out of ideas the
only area where kite is superior to
hisoka is that of Mind here hisoka has a
three and kite has a four but do note
that mind is not intelligence
intelligence has its own separate
category mind is more like the ability
to remain calm and collected so no
wonder hisoka doesn't have a high score
because that becomes increasingly
difficult as the battle erection sets in
however in every other category skill
body nen and intelligence kite and
hisoka are completely equal so the
initial conclusion is that kite is more
composed than hisoka but hisoka is
significantly more creative and this is
probably one of the least
straightforward match-ups in Hunter
Hunter because no one is just outright
stronger smarter or has more Oro than
the other the outcome of this fight
could go either way at least on paper
which means that a lot of this is going
to come down to attrition who can last
the longest and who has the best end
game options and that's what makes this
matchup quite exciting because both
combatants have abilities innately
designed to be versatile so much so that
theoretically both kite and hisoka can
be in any situation and always have the
right tool for the job guide of course
makes use of crazy slots and through the
power of restrictions he managed to turn
a single net ability into nine separate
net abilities the only problem being
that kite doesn't get to choose which
one he uses at any given time and he
also has to put up with a wisecracking
clown which means that he'll have to
deal with two clowns in this particular
fight meanwhile hisoka struts gloriously
into our Arena equipped with bungee gum
the net equivalent of handing clay to a
sculptor because hisoka can turn this
into just about anything both heartsu a
weirdly versatile but in opposite ways
hisoko for all intents and purposes has
one known ability that he can use in a
ton of different ways whereas kite
effectively has a whole ton of nen
abilities however each can only be used
in a super specific way like silent
Waltz for example there is literally
only one way that kite can use the
scythe and not only that but it must be
used to dispel the scythe and be able to
roll again and this I think is where I'm
starting to see a big problem because
realistically I don't think hisoka is
ever getting hit by this attack as soon
as it was summoned both gone and kilowa
started their Nan pants because
they knew that something was very very
wrong however it's worth noting that if
kite hadn't told them how to avoid it by
jumping straight up in exactly three
seconds then gone and killer may very
well have died but also that's because
they're inexperienced because most 11
year olds are whereas I think that
hisoka is experienced enough not only to
sense this feeling but also put two and
two together with the Scythe you know
what's he gonna do with that probably
swing it because that's the only way you
can use a scythe so let's get out of any
sort of swingy trajectory and just not
get hit sound like a good plan hisoka
sounds like a great plan of the hisoka
you always have the best plans hisoka I
Think I Love You other hisoka come here
hisoka that's an often forgotten aspect
of kite's abilities he has a lot of them
but they tend to function in pretty or
most painfully straightforward ways it's
the same with carbine I don't think
hisoka is ever getting hit by a
projectile with a predictable trajectory
which is good very good because to
kite's credit I don't think hisoka could
block any of these attacks with bungee
gum something we need to acknowledge is
that all of kite's attacks pack an
insane output due to their heavy
restrictions so hisoka isn't going to be
blocking these bullets as easily as say
goto's coins but when it comes to sheer
versatility fighting hisoka using kite's
moveset would scare me and I imagine
that for hisoka the whole Affair kind of
turns into an RPG boss battle where
after a while you learn all of kite's
moves and understand how to anticipate
them because kite can only use them in
particular set ways meanwhile kite is
always on edge constantly trying to
predict what kind of wacky way hisoka is
going to use bungee gum next I feel like
if kite is to win it would need to be
immediately which is possible if kite
can land a hit off any of his weapons
hisoka is going to take Serious
potentially even fatal damage the
problem being that the weapons we've
seen so far are so easily telegraphed a
scythe that acts like a scythe and a gun
that acts like a gun so it would need to
be be with a weapon that we haven't seen
yet something ideally less predictable
in technique as well because if the
other slots are all simple weapons and
they'll probably function similarly to
said weapons we've already seen hisoka
needs to be caught off guard by one of
the weapons and terminated because every
weapon hisoku survives is going to be a
dead weapon in the future so kite's got
a grand total of nine bites at this
horny clown Apple whereas hisoka has as
many bites as his gum-based imagination
will allow so in terms of intelligence
hisoka has an undeniable Edge not
because he's smarter than kite they're
both about equal but because kite isn't
allowed to plan because he never knows
what weapon he's going to be allowed to
use meanwhile hisoka can play it safe by
it his time enjoy the battle and as soon
as he sees a repeat weapon pop-up
Implement a counter in a battle of
attrition I can't see kite winning and a
lot of that comes down to the key idea
of Ingenuity hisoka isn't going to run
out of ideas whereas kite has a set
limit of ideas that are forced upon him
it's not so much that kite isn't
creative although his points and
creativity are not good but it's more
that he's heavily restricted in how he
can express his creativity now one
obscure factor that may actually help
kite is that in chapter 1 he carried a
katana however this weapon isn't present
when he appears again during the Chimera
Antarctic there are two theories for
this number one is that the katana
itself is actually a crazy thoughts role
a basic sword that didn't make sense and
number this one is that Togashi either
forgot or didn't care and just omitted
it in favor of a better idea considering
that when drawing chapter one he hadn't
even come close to fully conceiving of
nen yet and I suppose an in-world
explanation would probably be that crazy
slots has another restriction that only
allows the use of weapons it creates but
I only bring it up though because if
kite did have a sword as a separate
non-crazy slots option then it would
make him slightly more versatile and
slightly more able to plan against
hisoka something that also works well
for kite his range from what we've seen
hisoka almost always has an advantage in
close range combat because even in the
one fight hisoka did lose in the series
crolo always had to keep his distance
and from what we've seen kite is a
naturally long range combatant so he
doesn't have to fight against hisoka in
his preferred Arena however this is what
makes hisoka so insanely dangerous
though because he's very capable at
fighting to Mid to long range as well
bungee gum is said to have a maximum
stretch limit of 10 meters so anywhere
within a 10 meter radius of hisoka is
his territory and it's a very dangerous
range and so this is one match where we
should seriously consider physicality
primarily due to how even they both are
in almost everything else so kite
admittedly does look pretty scrawny but
he's not to be underestimated physically
or is he his feets are problematic
because in the 2011 anime he did show a
high level of martial arts skill against
yunju but that never happened in the
manga also allegedly shoot had a very
difficult time fighting against kite's
corpse which is notable because the
corpse couldn't use none at all so it
was completely vulnerable and still a
formidable Fighter the problem is we
don't know how much of this if any was
kite and how much of it was pito's
puppeteering ability speaking of Pito we
do know that kite was a fighter so
proficient that even though Peter won
they wanted to go at it again and with
that in mind it's hard to see kite as
anything less than a world-class fighter
which is good for him because that's
literally what hisoker is a floor master
of Heaven's Arena and one of the most
skilled battle clowns in the world so
one question you could ask is would
hisoka have fought so well against Peter
which is probably best saved for another
video but I think hisoka would have done
at least just as well as kite did we
also know that hisoka is a bit of a raw
power beast in the Phantom troop arm
wrestling rankings hisoka was third in
the entire group only uvgen and Finks
were physically stronger than him and to
be clear that makes hisoka stronger than
the Hulk that is Franklin who was fourth
in strength both are probably roughly
equal but uh then again if I had to
choose I would almost certainly give it
to hisoka kite is super skinny and in
the world of Nan combat look that's fine
because whoever can 10 renko and all of
the other things better kind of makes
physicality irrelevant however if we
have two nen users of equal skill
intelligence and or reserves then that
becomes a different matter physicality
all of a sudden becomes very relevant
again and I'd also say that kite has a
rather unfortunate net affinity for any
physical based combat against hisoka
hisoka is a transmuter and kite is a
conjurer thus making them nen ring
neighbors however hisoka's natural
Affinity is one step closer to
enhancement so when needed his Aura
investment in general enhancement is
going to be more cost effective than
kites so if they both had equal Aura
reserves then kites would be depleted
more rapidly again in a battle of
attrition if it did unfortunately come
down to a bit of a sogfest kite is in a
terrible situation because physically
and even with nen hisoka has the
advantage and you know I'm actually
starting to think that hisoka might be
one of the worst possible opponents for
Kai so let's examine the field of mind
because I think that holds kite's only
real chance at Victory consider this
situation should kite put up a good
fight which I think he would hisoka
would naturally get aroused and
potentially become vulnerable due to
doing less thinking up here and more
thinking down here however that's a bit
of a trade-off because when aroused yes
hisoka's intelligence does drop however
his instincts sharpen presenting an
entirely new problem for the opponent to
deal with but a problem that might not
necessarily be a problem for kite
because kite is a proper hunter in the
more traditional sense and is
exceptionally skilled with dealing with
instinctual beasts it's his entire area
of expertise and kite's whole heart to
his geared towards survival in the wild
against dangerous instinctual Powers so
the best case scenario is that with
hisoka in the state kite could use his
Superior calm and intimate experience to
get the better of hisoko while he's not
thinking at 100 but even then I think
it's a stretch when I first started
researching this video I thought that it
would be a lot more difficult to pick a
winner than it is and I'm still shocked
because when I look at these discussions
online I still see the majority of
people weighing in in kite's favor most
of the arguments I see are something
like well we don't know the rest of
kite's crazy slot moves which yeah it's
true but we've got to go based on what
we know and from what we know what I
would expect a more basic web weapons
with very straightforward functions they
can't be anything too complex or
versatile because that's the whole point
of having the crazy thoughts restriction
kite almost certainly has an array of
single function weapons which while
immensely powerful don't work well
against an experienced veteran like
hisoka and so I come back to this kite's
moveset seems developed for his hunting
style which is encountering beasts in
the wild but hisoka's moveset is
designed specifically for combat his
whole life is dedicated to fighting they
have different priorities hisoka is
geared for PVP where his kite is geared
for PVE which I think is always going to
give hisoka the edge in this sort of
hypothetical matchup in my opinion
hisoka is stronger more versatile and
more likely to win with each passing
second of the fight and while it's not
100 guaranteed to go hisoka's way yes he
could get caught off guard I do still
think that the odds are very much in his
favor and I would bet on hisoka but what
about you let me know who you think
would win in the comments below